twenty-five guys who used their
Photoshop skills to get hot girlfriends
that sounds pretty impressive to me
isn't it Ames anyway let's let's check
it out
oh I see it's one of those where they
make fun they make fun of guys for
having anime girlfriends I find this
very offensive you don't know their
story you don't know their past you
don't know their history you don't know
[ __ ] okay [ __ ] you for laughing at this
okay love just like genders come in very
different shapes and colors we're yes
we're in love we don't care who sees
that's goddamn right
and I want this stigma against anime
loving girlfriends to go away if Joe
Biden does it it's okay oh I see if John
Cena has an enemy our friend then it's
okay
having celebrities come out admitting
that they love their enemy wife can
really help bring out that the enemy
wife community forward Putin can have
enemy babes
so to break this horrible disgusting
stigma I'm going to Photoshop youtubers
with anime girlfriend to hopefully do
some positive impact with my voice on
this platform fifty three million I hope
we can finally make a difference I mean
so this can go from law to love
[Music]
what anime girlfriend do I think would
fit Jack I think Jack would fit quite
nicely with some the silent the silent
type you know to sort of compensate Yuki
Nagato
[Music]
this is really the fun part of Photoshop
doing the pencil tool I I love it so
much it's always so refreshing and
fulfilling it is so fun to see how he
follows the lines of jacksepticeye's
cheeks so nice very nice all right we
got one side finished let's say let's
move her a little closer there's such a
there's such a cute couple
hey Yuki hey hey hey hey have some
decency damn I ship them now
honestly I ship them that is cute
you can see the crowd just being so
jealous of of jacksepticeye having such
a hot babe girlfriend let me do a little
bit of shading a little bit of touch-up
and this baby is good to go
[Music]
the fact that Jack comes out and shows
his support even though people are
clearly hating on their relationship I'm
proud of you jack
I really am for the first time I think
ever I'm extremely proud and I want to
say you have my fullest support I if you
want me to be your best man at at your
wedding proud of my man jacksepticeye
for showing his love for Yuki Nagato Big
Ups already you can see disgusting hate
comments calling him a weeb today's
society just haven't adapted yet but one
day damn it
hell yeah wife for life I've only
suspected and I think we all know deep
down that keemstar it's the biggest
anime fan on the planet that's why I'm
not gonna photoshop keemstar I'm gonna
Photoshop scarce the only motions behind
those glasses are fear and screaming
help me I would rather be with a real
girlfriend I'm here I'm here for your
scares okay I care about you despite
what you may think I care why do I do
what I do cuz I'm a goddamn hero
three girls a redhead a blonde and a
brunette surely there must be an enemy
equivalent yes I think I found your
enemy girlfriend scarce scarce I'm gonna
hit you up with something way better
some love live girls we got hockey
Nishiki know we got hanayo kazumi and of
course the blonde my personal favorite
you're welcome
Arri IIC
[Music]
all right we got one girlfriend we got
two girlfriends
we got three girlfriends scarce you're a
lucky man you're a lucky son of a man
why am I doing this I don't
[Music]
disgusting drinking naked foul women hot
anime babes having a great time with
scarce in Vegas I applaud you scarce I
applaud you for coming out publicly to
show how much you love anime from from
one anime man to another john scares
exposed it was photoshopped alone this
is a beautiful thing this is a thing
worth celebrating I think we have time
for one more
jacksepticeye replied oh yeah dude we go
way back
love me some Yuki Oh goo I think we've
all suspected but if there's what was
one person so influential that his love
for anime could change
thank you yes this is the perfect image
who should we put there he moto Oh
Maruchan I'm a little jealous but I
think I really think I really ship them
I really do I really shipped them quite
a line damn okay whoa
[Music]
Trump he lacks to hump I don't know what
rhymes with hump and he may babes
oh not love he really didn't want to be
president he really just wanted to stay
home and watch anime which I can relate
what do you think I want to be here he
wants to UM anime babes all night long
any merit babes and babes and me
[Music]
haha yes I'm proud of you drug finally
you did something worth celebrating I
applaud you Trump I applaud you a lot of
people couldn't get a girl like that a
lot of people don't know alright so that
was anime video anyway wait what is this
how could this be
no no how he must have gone back in time
resurrected himself and stole my gf my
real-life girlfriend this can't be
happening mercy
[Music]
you